we toured together in 2010 a bunch of us
on that tour bands on that tour myself
Andy and I remembered you were hilarious
on the tour you were fantastic and I'm
so happy for the success you've had
since those days but you love to have a
good time I love that to her
I love we had a great time on that tour
you had a really good time Andy and I
had an okay time there are levels too
who had a good time and who had a great
time I was the only black come on
hanging out I remember I remember one
night though I got so drunk I remember
working here I got so you were a writer
here and then we all went on - yeah yeah
we went and and we went on the Thursday
I ran the longest bar tab you ever gonna
see in your life and I bet no one has
ever ran one longer than this I went on
a Thursday have some drinks we're about
this was here nearly in LA I left I left
work here and now I'm gonna have some
drinks and forgot my car woke up Friday
was like man where's my car so I called
the barrios I guess here I said okay I'm
gonna come pick it back up so I went
Friday and I was like well this Friday
- have some drinks and you got your card
there yeah I left again without my car
so then I was like man so I called
Saturday and was like he was my car
theater again and I got there and it was
Saturday so
I love my card again and then I call
Sunday and I was like look just come
outside and give it to me all right then
I went there and I kept calling the guy
and he won't come outside and give it to
me so I had to go in so add some more
drinks mail it to me nobody can beat
that bar tab I bet you do you remember
this this is a true thing that you did
they just blew my mind
I think you know what I'm talking about
we were staying we were touring city to
city city we were staying in this hotel
room and they had a minibar oh yes they
had a minibar and you and I would filled
with all the little bottles okay you can
take over at any point
go look I drank all the little bottles
right but there's too much to like pay
for those so I went to a liquor store
and I bought all the little bottles in
there and I replaced them
[Laughter]
only one they didn't have with Hennessy
it was like you spent a long time
exactly recreated I did it and you did
it you did it
I'm reviewing you could remember what
they were I do I remember oh my child I
remember you are waiting and was like
dude what are you doing
like hold on everyone back it's gotta be
just just right turn turtle labels
forward and everything like yo my
peepees though
you